oh hello
welcome today i'm going to be taking
what is a newfangled version of the
myers-briggs test a personality test to
determine
what my career should be it's like i'm
back in high school so that's super
exciting
apparently this new version breaks down
your personality in a
variety of ways apparently there are
four categories there are analysts
diplomats sentinels and explorers like
those colonialist
bastards that took over the western
hemisphere
if i had to guest out i would either be
in the analyst category or in the
sentinel category
but before we get to that let's talk
about our sponsor raycon
because this particular video is brought
to you by the greatest pair of earbuds
that god or man has ever created and if
you go down into the link right now you
click on it
get 15 off this fantabulous pair of
earbuds that you will absolutely
treasure every day of your waking
existence
shall we begin let's do it we shall all
right so you got your mouse over there
on your right hand i do
and so just scroll down okay and
i enjoy vibrant social events with a lot
of people
no you often spend time exploring
unrealistic yet intriguing ideas
mildly agree your travel plans are more
likely to look like a rough list of
ideas than a detailed
itinerary kind of agree you often think
about what you should have said in a
conversation long after it has taken
place
disagree that is for people who make
mistakes if your friend is sad about
something your first instinct
is to support them emotionally not to
try to solve their problems strongly
disagree
sads are only solved by solutions people
can rarely upset you
mildly agree you often rely on other
people to be the ones to start a
conversation and keep it going disagree
why would i rely on other people to
start a conversation they might tell me
about their lives that sounds awful
if you have temporarily put your plans
on hold you make sure it is your top
priority to get back on track
as soon as possible strongly agree we're
just going to go full extremes here
you rarely worry if you made a good
impression on someone you met
generally agree it would be a challenge
for you to spend the whole weekend by
yourself without feeling
bored i'll disagree if i have books if i
have books
if you're you're more of a detail
oriented than a big picture person
strongly disagree
you're very affectionate with people you
care about shockingly strongly agree i
have children guys
i don't like you but i like my kids you
have a careful and methodical approach
to life yes i'll agree
you are still bothered by mistakes you
made a long time ago agree
at parties and similar events you can
mostly be found further away from the
action
well see this is weird so in the past
the answer would have been agree
like by preference yes by actuality no
see this is sort of the problem right
like i prefer to be further away from
the action but i've been dragged at so
many parties into the center of the
action
i've been specifically invited to
weddings where i don't know anybody
just so that they can put me in their
wedding videos i assume that
it means like whether i want to be in
the center of the action so uh so i'll
like mildly agree you often find it
difficult to relate to people who let
their emotions guide them ugly
when looking for a movie to watch you
spend ages browsing the catalog
yeah i agree but that's because i've
seen most everything that's good you can
stay
calm under a lot of pressure agree
when in a group of people you do not
know you have no problem jumping right
into their conversation strongly agree
you are dedicated
and focused on your goals only rarely
getting sidetracked
definitely agree if you make a mistake
you tend to start doubting
yourself your abilities or your
knowledge
um no disagree when at a social event
you rarely try to introduce yourself to
new people and mostly talk to the ones
you already know agree but it's not like
everybody like who really just like
really enjoys going to parties and
randomly introducing themselves around
emily
emily of course emily the friendliest
person in the room you usually lose
interest in a discussion when it gets
philosophical disagree that's actually
when it gets good
you would never let yourself cry in
front of others what is crying
why do you cry i understand now why you
cry
i don't know why you cry but it's
something i can never do
terminator 2 quote guys you feel more
drawn to places with a bustling and busy
atmosphere then to more quiet and
intimate ones disagree
you like discussing different views and
theories on what the world could look
like in the future
agree when it comes to making
life-changing choices you mostly listen
to your heart rather than
your head disagree you cannot imagine
yourself dedicating your life to the
study of something you cannot see touch
or experience
major disagree you usually prefer to get
your revenge
rather than forgive yeah man oh yeah
sometimes forgiveness is actually the
best revenge seriously like if somebody
does something very bad to you and then
you forgive them
they have no leverage over you see
people like to feel better about
themselves or having done something bad
because now they think that you
think something bad about them so if you
forgive them you take away their
leverage in just a moment you'll learn
what type of personality i am aside from
a sociopath but first
let's talk about the greatest pair of
earbuds on the market i'm talking of
course about these
the raycons you know about raycons
because you've heard me talk about them
before go check that out right now by
clicking on the link below and you get
off raycons are incredible for a variety
of reasons one they sound just as good
as any of their earbuds on the markets
and they will cost you like 50
of what other earbuds would second they
sound really good third they come in a
variety of colors so you can really
customize it to your needs
and fourth they actually fit your ear
they're not one size fits all there's no
wires there's no stems they look really
good and they figure
properly they come with a variety of
fits there's like a little metal card
that they come with with these
rubber pieces at the end so you can
customize how it fits your ear so they
don't fall out
raycon they sound fantastic they
basically cancel most
noise they're everyday e25 earbuds those
are the ones that you're looking for
click the link in the description and
you get 15
off go check them out right now raycons
they're excellent
you often make decisions on a whim
disagree
the time you spend by yourself often
ends up being more interesting and
satisfying than the time you spend with
other people strongly agree
you often put special effort into
interpreting the real meaning of a
message of a song
or a movie agree you always know exactly
what you want yeah agree
you rarely think back on the choices
you've made and wonder what you could
have done differently mostly agree with
that because i spend a lot of time
thinking about my choices before i make
them
as all thinking people should you tend
to focus on present realities rather
than future possibilities i
agree you often have a hard time
understanding other people's feelings
agree i kind of do understand other
people's feelings i just think they're
stupid
so i'll actually disagree with that like
i fully understand my wife's feelings
and i fully understand my kids feelings
and so
i'm very empathetic with people that i
care about but if your feelings are
unjustified
i can understand them but that does not
mean that i agree with them or think
that they should be the basis for
decision making when starting to work on
a project
you prefer to make as many decisions
upfront as possible strongly agree
when you know someone thinks highly of
you also wonder how long it will be
until they become disappointed in you
disagree they'll never be disappointed
in me you feel comfortable just walking
up to someone you find interesting
and striking up a conversation so you
used to be disagree now
pretty strongly agree when as you get
older you kind of like you're like you
know what
effing man like okay fine let's just
talk to somebody interesting
you often drift away into daydreaming
about various ideas or scenarios
agree as my producers can tell you when
they're desperately trying to tell me
which ad to read next
you look after yourself first and others
come in second disagree have a family
even when you have planned a
particularly daily routine you usually
just end up doing what you feel like in
any given moment disagree your mood can
change
very quickly disagree you often
contemplate the reasons for human
existence or the meaning of life
agree you often talk about your own
feelings or emotions
i i would go with disagree but my
feelings are pretty much out there on
the surface so i feel like i never have
to discuss them so much like i feel like
my producers know that like if i'm
pissed off i'll just say i'm pissed to
offer something so
i don't know mildly disagree there
you've got detailed educational career
development plans stretching several
years into the future
i agree you rarely dwell on your regrets
agree but that's because i've had an
amazingly
baller life spending time in a dynamic
atmosphere with lots of people around
quickly makes you feel drained and in
need of a
getaway yeah agree agree that's what
shabbos is for
you see yourself as more of a realist
than a visionary
i'll actually agree with that i'll agree
with that you find it easy to empathize
with the person who's gone through
something
you never have i know everyone wants me
to say disagree here but the truth is
that i actually think that the mark of
thinking is being able to empathize with
an experience you've never had i mean
that's what human rationality is about
your personal work style is closer to
spontaneous bursts of energy
than to organized and consistent efforts
i disagree i'm pretty organized in how i
work
your emotions control you more than you
control them disagree after a long and
exhausting week a fun party is just what
you need strongly disagree
you frequently find yourself wondering
how technological advancement could
change
everyday life and disagree you always
consider
how your actions might affect other
people before doing something
agree you still honor the commitments
you made even if you have a change of
heart super agree you rarely feel
insecure
agree see results okay let's see guys
the architect intj
wow you knew it okay everybody in the
room is like
called it we're gonna read you your
results back to you
okay and get your reaction all right
other architects at school are often
called
bookworms those are this personality
type likely identify with that label
fair i mean uh it's better than not
knowing
like what's like are serious and prefer
to design
and carry out effective plans rather
than waste their time with foolish
distractions like gossip
wow that's actually quite accurate yeah
all right they typically apply a sense
of perfectionism and even morality to
all their work
anyone who can't keep up with architects
processes or doesn't see the point of
them
is likely to lose their respect wow
is that some truth yeah yeah this is
right
facts don't care about your personality
type architects you may know
frederic nietzsche okay elon musk
christopher nolan yeah all right
vladimir putin
oh ride the bear
arnold schwarzenegger it's come full
circle i actually quoted arnold
schwarzenegger in that
video so which one confront you all as a
friend
correct absolutely 100 true
that is 100 true anybody with a lot of
friends has no friends
and will be alone at their funeral the
arctic personality type are looking for
an intellectual soulmate more than
anything else people who aren't equipped
for such a relationship
as seen as boring architects need to
share their expansive ideas making
chronic small talk
is something they typically avoid all of
that is true
children must be taught how to think not
what to think
absolutely true listen you have to
instill values in your kids but you
really do have to explain why
you're doing it i'm not an authoritarian
there's sort of
several different parenting styles and
there's a difference between
authoritative and authoritarian
authoritarian as you just lay down the
law and authoritative is you lay down
why but you explain why you're doing
what you're doing
and yeah i'm the latter the role of
genius is not to complicate the simple
but to simplify the complicated that's
i literally think that's what i do for a
job my job is to try and boil down
complex ideas into into ways that people
can understand them
that's literally the podcast is so yeah
agree architects want to tackle
intellectually interesting work with
little outside interference
time consuming management techniques
like trust building gatherings progress
meetings and long sessions that look
backward rather than
than forward only annoy architects
all they need be they subordinates
colleagues or managers
is to meet their goals with the highest
standard of technical excellence and it
may help them if they're surrounded by
people who share those values if anyone
surrounds them
correct that's great that is exactly
right
as my producers know from trying to get
me to do meetings and or anything else
i have i won't my work style is wham bam
thank you man
if they see co-workers valuing social
activities and accepting good enough
workmanship over excellence
there's likely to be trouble
ziprecruiter.com
okay that was there's a lot that's
actually pretty damp to accurate
good stuff guys all right that was that
was more fun than usual
[Music]
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel so you don't miss out on
any of our content